With Captain Marvel fresh off its box office-conquering
opening weekend, Marvel is already thinking
ahead to its next blockbuster,
"I like this one"
having just
dropped the official trailer for the superhero-infused
crossover event of the year.
The new Avengers: Endgame clip is clearly
built to stoke fan anticipation.
Every moment seems to have something important
to say, and comes with the potential of deeper
meanings, hidden explanations, and misleading
misdirections.
Let's break it down and take a look at the
details you might've missed in the newest
Avengers: Endgame trailer.
And just so we're all clear, potential and
rumored spoilers ahead… don't say we didn't
warn you.
We've seen this before: the Avengers: Endgame
Super Bowl spot opened on a quick sequence
that sped through ten MCU characters, most
of whom had died or been snapped in Infinity
War.
Everything was in black, white, and red all
over.
This time around, the red-highlighted footage
is back, and also specifically highlights
some different faces… like Tony Stark, Steve
Rogers, Thor, and Okoye... four characters
who did not get snapped.
It's pretty widely known that Avengers: Endgame
is the final movie in Chris Hemsworth, Robert
Downey Jr., and Chris Evans' Marvel Studios
contracts.
That doesn't mean they're definitively done
with their characters...but if you're gonna
retire a role, you could do worse than saving
half the universe, you know?
Meanwhile, that red coloring still seems highly
symbolic.
Red is often connected to blood and death.
But, as we've theorized before, it could have
something to do with the red Reality Stone
and its possible usage in un-snapping the
world.
Will that gem be instrumental in defeating
Thanos once and for all?
If this montage means what we think it might,
keep your eyes peeled for that scarlet stone...
One of the most exciting moments in the first
trailer was the arrival of Scott Lang at the
Avengers HQ with his Quantum-powered Ant-Van.
While the presence of Lang in Endgame is a
pleasant if not a particularly surprising
revelation, one attention-getting moment occurred
when Cap and Black Widow ask each other about
what they're seeing:
"Is this an old message?”
“Ant-Man?
Ant-Man?
I know you know that."
"It's the front door."
Many detail-oriented fans seized on her not-quite-answer
to suggest that the footage wasn't actually
live.
The word "Archive" in the upper left corner
of the screen also led some to theorize that
perhaps the security camera clip was, in fact,
a very "old message"... and from a different
year entirely.
In the new trailer, things seem to point toward
a post-snap arrival for Lang.
Ant-Man features heavily throughout the trailer,
but one scene in particular shows a befuddled
Scott looking at a telephone pole plastered
with missing person posters.
While this could be highlighting a particularly
active day for kidnappers, chances are the
scene puts Lang firmly after the snap as he
starts to piece together what happened.
One of the biggest questions that's swirled
since the dust from Infinity War settled was
if, how, and when time travel would factor
into Avengers: Endgame.
Ant-Man and the Wasp explored the potential
of the Quantum Realm, opening up the opportunity
for that mode of inter-dimensional transportation
to come into play in Endgame.
And we know from that film's post-credits
scene that the Quantum Realm is entangled
with time travel in some way:
"And don't get sucked into a time vortex.
We won't be able to save you."
And as this newest trailer seems to indicate,
it appears more and more likely that audiences
will be pulled around the MCU timeline in
Endgame.
The Super Bowl spot showed clips of Liberty
Island surrounded by apparently abandoned
ships as well as Citi Field looking ominously
abandoned… and not just because the Mets
missed the playoffs again.
The Statue of Liberty showed up for a second
time in the new trailer, but so did another,
more interesting clip.
Halfway through the trailer, we see a short
sequence of the Avengers' Quinjet coming out
of the clouds with a city in front of them,
except this time the buildings are all lit
up.
Could they be celebrating getting the power
grid back on post-Decimation?
Or are we witnessing our heroic crew heading
back to the past?
A quick shot in the trailer shows a very angry
Nebula whipping out her swords and making
a run at an unseen foe, Papa Thanos, perhaps?
The likelihood of Nebula playing a key role
in the film is high, especially considering
her crucial part in the original Infinity
Gauntlet comics event.
But another interesting thing to notice about
the scene is the landscape behind her.
The scenery is quite a mess of fire and flame
and even a little reminiscent of the battle
on Titan from Infinity War.
Of course, at the end of the previous Avengers
movie, we're not quite sure where Thanos ends
up.
Some have suggested that his new home could
be anywhere from within the Soul Stone to
Wakanda itself.
However, reports surfaced online that Disney
shareholders were allegedly shown a clip that
put the kibosh on either of those two theories.
One more time for anyone who wasn't paying
attention earlier:
"spoiler alert."
Still here?
In the clip, Nebula reportedly says she knows
where Thanos is and, coupled with an energy
signature that's been picked up on out in
space, heads off to find him.
Could this clip of Nebula on a battle-torn
planet actually take place on the long-rumored
"Titan 2" that Thanos withdrew to after his
work was done?
One of the most glaring things missing from
Infinity War was the anxiously anticipated
reunion between Tony Stark and Steve Rogers.
While the two leaders had technically buried
the hatchet thanks to Steve's letter and accompanying
emergency cell phone, bruised egos and hurt
feelings take a while to heal.
Of course, a Thanos-level apocalypse goes
a long way toward helping a reconciliation
occur, and it's hard not to believe that once
Cap and Iron Man got into the same room together,
they'd be able to figure things out one way
or another.
The bigger question at this point is when
in the world, or off of the world, that meeting
will take place.
While the new trailer doesn't show the first
scene where they set eyes on each other, we
do at long last get a glimpse of the two brothers
in arms suited up, walking side by side, and
man does it feel good.
And on that note… what are those special
suits for, anyway?
Quantum exploration?
Time travel?
Both?
Well, regardless, with Iron Man and Cap finally
together again, the world feels a little,
just a little, bit safer.
Unless...this trailer is another misdirect.
Like when Marvel revealed an Infinity War
trailer showing Hulk running alongside the
Avengers in Wakanda.
Which was a scene that never happened in the
film.
They wouldn't do that to us again… would
they?
Would they?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.